Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Rough. Hello Walter.
>> Hello Martin. Yes. I feel I I also feel
like that.
>> I actually feel fine.
>> Oh, that's great.
>> Yes.
>> Well, that's what I said. I also feel
like that.
>> Oh, you're also feeling fine.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. It's going to be boring then.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, maybe we must just go
and then we'll start over when we're
feeling not so good.
>> Yes. Okay. Let's do that.
>> So, we're talking about an abundance of
rain.
>> Yes. It's still following on the
previous two of will you be able to
stand?
>> Why does that ship look in such a mess
there?
>> Well, people can remember it was hitting
that iceberg.
>> Okay. But why is it messed up in the
middle if it hit the iceberg from the
front?
>> It's a bit difficult to get it to show.
Maybe that's how what's going to happen
after a big shaking that choke it.
>> I think that ship didn't only hit a
iceberg.
I think it hit a tempestuous wind called
Euroidon.
>> Yes.
>> And uh it's in a it's in bad shape, but
it's still afloat.
>> It's still a float.
>> Yeah.
>> It might look as if it's about to fall
or fail or break up, but it will go
through,
>> I think. Do you think it hit the island
of Malta? Maybe as well.
>> Maybe.
>> Hey, military arm of the beast.
I hope that the people um stayed on the
ship and didn't take the rafts.
>> I think they're all hiding in the back
there.
>> Yeah. No, no, I think it's we can talk a
little bit about how
how will we be able or what must we do
to be still on that ship. Yes, as long
as it uh receives that rain and that
bird is hovering above,
then I'll take my chances on that ship.
I agree.
>> Let's open with a word of prayer. Our
heavenly father, thank you so much for
bringing us together again.
Yes, Lord, we are living in momentous
times and we need your blessing and your
holy spirit more than ever. So we ask
that you enlighten our minds and also
guide this discussion in Jesus name.
Amen.
Just before we dive into this maybe I
just want to do an announcement again
that um we are going to be traveling
again early next year.
>> God willing.
>> God willing definitely. Uh so we'll be
visiting
um New Zealand, Oakland,
Melbourne and Australia and then Malan
Bumbi. But uh for more information,
there's still more information to
follow, but uh I'll put some links and
contact details in the description for
people that are interested.
>> Okay. Okay. So now we can dive into
this. All right, Martin. So once this
great conflict takes place,
Then uh if we take our minds back to
what happened on in Paul's journey on
the way to Rome
>> when they crashed into the island of
Malta,
there was also an abundance of rain
>> and he had to deal with a couple of
serpents that tried to interfere with
his ministry,
but they were useless.
>> Shaken off.
>> They were shaken off. So what how do we
stand when things look so forboding?
>> You see, we've clearly shown that's why
it became a third episode
how things are really getting to a
confrontation.
We're heading for the confrontation
there. There is no way in which to avoid
it and so we have to meet the iceberg
head on.
And yes, let's bump into Malita and see
how it goes.
>> Yeah. And it is, isn't it interesting
that it's also going along with trouble
in the camp?
>> Yes.
>> So on the ship, it's not all roses and
sunshine.
>> Do you think some might be shaken off by
the shocks?
>> Well,
>> some might want to lower some ships and
get off.
>> Yeah. And get out of there. Eh, see if
they can join the ecumenical movement in
the last minute. Maybe that'll help
them.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, it's not going to cut it, right?
>> No. So, we must know what to do and how
to stand for this.
>> No. Stay on the ship. Stay on the ship.
Will you stand, Martin? We need to pray
for the latter rain.
For the outpouring of the latter rain.
But will you receive the latter rain if
you have refused the former rain? But
now please just let's explain or explain
what is the former rain because it
sounds so good and maybe okay let's pray
for the latter rain but and what what
does it mean? What what's the former
rain?
>> Well what does the latter rain do?
Doesn't it bring the final ripening
>> of the harvest.
>> But uh in order to grow to a point where
there is something to ripen you have to
have the former rain.
>> Mhm. So your first experience in
Christianity
is uh what makes the seed germinate that
fell onto good ground.
>> And some of those seeds don't
necessarily fall onto good ground. They
might even sprout, but then uh some of
them on stony ground. They don't have
enough root.
>> When a wind comes, they're gone. Some of
them fall amongst the weeds
and they get choked by the cares of this
world and they give up and some of them
fall onto good ground and then they
yield much fruit. That's it.
>> They won't yield the good fruit if uh
there's no latter rain.
>> Yeah.
>> Because that brings the ripening.
>> So it's like uh the virgins and their
oil. If they neglected the oil,
>> yeah,
>> the lessons that the Holy Spirit wants
to teach you,
>> that uh changes your character and bring
it into harmony with the heavenly
character. If that hasn't happened, then
you might uh end up with too little oil
>> and then you have to go and find it. But
there's no time
>> because while you're running around
and if you neglected the word, people
will be running to and fro trying to
find it, but they will not find it.
>> And then the bridegroom comes and those
that had their lamps trimmed and had
enough oil went in.
And the others were running to and fro
and arrived at the door, knocked and
said,
>> "Yeah,
>> did we not do this? Did we not do that?"
And he said, "Uh, sorry. I just don't
know who you are."
>> Yeah.
>> Hey, Martin, that's a serious issue.
>> And we will get to that later on. But
there's a real there's a real uh the
problem, not the real, but the real
problem that happened to those is there
was a eye problem.
Oh, they had an eye problem.
>> Yes. Not an eye one, but we'll get to
that.
>> But even an eye one.
>> Even that one as well.
>> Because in Laitia, they could have
purchased the Cedrium eyesolve.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Mhm.
>> That the literal laudier was famous for.
>> Yeah.
>> So that they could see properly.
>> Distinguish between good and evil,
right, truth and error.
>> Yeah.
So if we state it then the early reign
is the working of the Holy Spirit. Yes.
>> In your bo in your heart.
>> Yes.
>> In your mind
>> and discernment.
>> And you know what? I've been working on
our next WhatsApp prof.
And I don't want to jump the gun.
>> Yeah. But an advert's always good.
>> Just a little advertisement.
Well, Martin, if you think about uh
discernment
and you think about doctrines
>> and you know the Bible says take heed of
the doctrine. I know the pope is not in
favor of doctrine but uh that's his
problem. Not
>> the Bible is in favor of it. The Bible
is in favor of doctrine. And the Bible
says, you know, that if you if you do
what is right and you follow Christ, you
will know of the doctrine.
>> There's no reason not to know of the
doctrine.
And if you think of all the false
doctrines that have been pedled
that somehow
place a dark
>> foroding light on the character of God,
then I don't know how some of the
churches will face the judgment
because what they have done to the
character of God is incredible. Just
take for example,
>> I'm jumping the gun now. I'm being
naughty. But uh take the doctrine of the
immortality of the soul
>> and combine it with the doctrine of
hell.
What do you have then? Then you have
eternal torment for those that don't
make it.
>> Immortality but suffering for eternity.
>> What does that do to the character of
God?
>> Well, let's say you do make it, then you
end up in purgatory and then you suffer
again. What does that do to the
character of God?
>> There's nothing left.
>> When Isaiah 53 quite plainly tells us by
his stripes we are healed.
>> The suffering that was due to us fell
upon him. Right? I mean these terrible,
terrible doctrines
or the doctrine of arbitrary
predestination
>> where God predestines you to to hell
before you are even born
>> or predestines you to heaven whether you
want to go or not.
>> Yeah.
And I mean these horrendous doctrines
that place such a
such a evil light on the character of
God.
>> I was just wondering, you know, Martin,
is it is it surprising that so many
people become atheists rather than
believe in such a deity?
>> No, for sure not. or if you don't
believe in such a deity and you become
an atheist but you don't necessarily do
evil things others again will say well
obviously such a god doesn't exist and
they can become infidels
>> and I think that the church will have to
give an account
>> for sure they will
>> why did you preach such doctrines did
you find them in the Bible or did you
distort them out of the Bible
>> teachings the commandment what for
doctrine the commandments of men. That
that's a that's a doctrine concocted.
It's not in the Bible.
>> No. And then you have this interesting
story
that people believe that uh they are
chosen
>> to set up the kingdom
when God is the one that rewards those
that have been faithful and they will be
part of the first resurrection
and uh those that are living when Christ
comes they will be rewarded with a
translation and those are the heirs of
the kingdom.
Not these self-appointed ones that are
setting up a kingdom down here, right?
>> And with all this confusion out there,
how can the latter rain fall on
confusion?
>> No. So that's why there's a specific
group and a specific criteria
for the people that will receive the
latter reign.
>> Yes.
>> And it does not and that does not happen
by affiliation.
>> No. And and it's important to know the
latter reign doesn't necessarily fall on
those who know the truth.
>> No, that's exactly what I'm saying. So
if you affiliate with a certain church,
that does not guarantee that you'll
receive the latter rain.
>> So you might have all the truth, you
might know all the truth, but you don't
live up to it.
>> Yes.
>> Then you haven't been changed by the
former reign, the early reign,
>> the Holy Spirit working.
>> In other words, you didn't have any
growth.
If we take it back to the disciples.
>> Yes.
>> They couldn't receive the latter reign
>> until there was unity amongst them.
>> Yes. And that only became that only came
after the crucifixion.
>> Correct. And then you know the Bible
says that they were of one accord
>> even in terms of the doctrine
>> of the disciples. So that's very
important. Right. So you must understand
and you must know the doctrine, but you
must also have been transformed by it.
We must put in a link again. Total
transformation.
I think people can watch that again as
well.
>> You're staring.
>> It's okay.
>> Mai and the gate.
>> Yeah, actually um that was in prophets
and kings. We were studying that with
the youth.
>> Beautiful rendition of Morai and the
gate as well in there.
>> Okay. So they but they can go and watch
your total transformation series.
>> Well, let's read a little bit here what
we read in these inspired writings.
The latter rain ripening earth's harvest
represents the spiritual grace that
prepares the church for the coming of
the son of man.
Now when it says prepares the church,
is that all of it or those that have
grown to the point where they can
receive it?
>> Yeah.
it to be part of God's remnant church.
There's certain criteria. We know that
it's in Revelation 12:17 and Revelation
14. But
you have to do those things. Yes. And
then it qualifies for a church. And then
in your person, you also have to do it.
You know, and when Paul lists the things
that we once were.
>> Mhm. And then he says, "And such were
some of you,
but you have been washed. You have been
transformed."
>> So, but unless the former rain has
fallen, there will be no life. There's
no seed to ripen.
The green blade will not spring up
unless the early showers have done the
work. The latter rain can bring no seed
to perfection. Isn't that exactly what
we said? That's exactly. So if we can
just make it a picture,
you are currently now receiving the
early reign
>> constantly.
>> Constantly. And the way that you react
to it
>> and that's why we have wives to remind
us where we are on this path. They know
exactly where we are on the path.
>> I'm not saying anything. You're in
trouble on your own.
>> Must I bear this cross by myself here?
No.
>> All right.
>> So, we are we are constantly we are in
the time now of the early reign. How the
Holy Spirit works on you. This is how
you prepare
to get on that boat. Many have in a
great measure failed to receive the
former rain. They have not obtained all
the benefits that God has thus provided
for them. They expect that the lack will
be supplied by the latter rain. That's a
wishful thinking. Yeah.
>> Unless we are daily advancing in the
exemplification of the active Christian
virtues, we shall not recognize the
manifestations of the Holy Spirit and
the latter rain. It's like being tuned
in.
>> Yeah. Yes. And if you don't have that um
that radio perfectly, it's going to, you
know,
>> make a noise.
>> Yeah. You know, I was thinking God gave
us prophecy, right?
>> Mhm.
>> And the prophecy is to tell us where we
are in the stream of time.
>> Yeah.
>> If you say, "I don't need this stuff."
>> Then what incentive is there to say,
"Wow, am I right with God?"
>> No. No.
>> Am I ready? As the Bible says, "Prepare
to meet thy God." Am I ready? Well,
let's put it back a few years
when that
worldwide shock came.
>> How many people panicked?
>> Panicked because am I ready?
>> Yes.
>> And now what? We went back into a little
slumber again.
>> Some went into such a nervous state. It
was it was shocking to watch.
It may be falling on hearts all around
us, but we shall not discern or receive
it.
That's rather sad.
It is.
>> Divine grace is needed at the beginning.
Divine grace at every step of advance
and divine grace alone can complete the
work.
The Bible is pretty clear. Without him,
we can do
>> nothing.
>> Nothing. nothing. There's no place for
us to rest in a careless attitude. We
must never forget the warnings of
Christ. Watch unto prayer. Watch and
pray always. A connection with the
divine agency every moment is essential
to our progress.
We may have had a measure of the spirit
of God, but by prayer and faith, we are
continually to seek more of the spirit.
It will never do to cease our efforts.
There's never a time when you have
arrived. Right?
>> It's very clear. And that's how many
times does Paul say you have to die?
>> Daily.
>> And the funny thing is when you think,
well, I sort of have this little thing
under control.
>> Then something happens when you realize
that it is totally not under your
control. Uh, what isn't there a
scripture that says we should pray for
tribulation or for trials? What? Please
stop now.
You're making my life a misery.
If we do not progress, if we do not
place ourselves in an attitude to
receive both the former and the latter
rain, we shall lose our souls and the
responsibility will lie at our own door.
Ask ye of the Lord rain in the time of
the latter rain. This is biblical.
>> Do not rest satisfied in the ordinary
course of the season. Rain will fall.
Ask for it.
>> So why are you asking for it because it
God's going to supply it.
>> All right. It's very important that we
understand motive.
Am I asking for the latter reign to have
confirmation that uh you know I'm one of
the chosen ones
>> and can now inform everybody?
>> No.
>> Or am I asking for the latter reign
because I have the same compassion that
he had for humanity?
>> That's the one. And then that's why I'm
asking why do you ask for it? Because
it's for you. It's God wants you to
realize that you need him.
>> Yes.
>> You need the Holy Spirit
>> cuz without him you can do nothing.
>> Yeah.
>> So the convocation of the church as in
camp meetings, the assemblies of the
home church and all occasions where
there is personal labor for souls are
God's appointed opportunities for giving
the early and the latter rain. That's
one thing that I've realized in my life.
Martin is it's definitely true that the
sword of the spirit is a double-edged
sword.
>> Yeah, that's very true. Yeah.
>> When you give
>> Mhm.
>> you receive more back.
We've got the school of the prophets now
at the moment, right? Mhm.
>> And uh we are giving courses on
Revelation and Daniel and where we are
in the stream of time and trying to
connect all the dots and pulling it
together.
And it's not the first time we're doing
this, right?
>> No, it's the third time.
>> It's the third time. And I find it
amazing every time that you do it,
you actually become more edified
than than maybe they do
>> because all of a sudden you see
connections that you never saw before.
>> God works so in your with your with your
you the one presenting.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> So if you don't share,
>> you don't receive.
>> You don't receive.
If you don't pour out your cup, how can
you expect it to be filled again?
>> Yeah.
>> And if you if it does get filled, does
it get filled with exactly the same
things that you poured out last time or
is there more?
>> There's more. And that God promises
that.
>> Yes.
>> It's like the um talents.
>> Yeah.
>> The one that kept the talent didn't help
anything.
>> No.
>> But when he started utilizing the
talent,
>> Yes.
>> he got more back. So this is very
important. If you don't share your
faith, how are you going to in the
latter reign suddenly be a super sharer?
>> Yeah. It's not going to be a a magic
wand turning you and making you now
sharp. It's like it said there, don't
think that what you lack now with the
early reign. Yes, you will get then get
made up.
>> All right. You don't have to be an
eloquent speaker. You don't have to.
It's the little things that matter. It's
the little touch here, the little
attention there, the kind word here, the
encouragement there. That's what makes a
difference. And your life, Martin, do
people watch you?
>> Oh,
okay. Yes, definitely.
>> Yeah,
>> constantly that people have a magnifying
glass on you.
>> Okay. Can you be fake?
>> You can, but they're going to catch you
out. What if you think that you're now
in a private place and well now you're
not under scrutiny. You can do whatever
you like. If you don't live it, you
don't have it.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> Otherwise, you're a hypocrite.
>> If you if you live fake,
it's what's that? How does it the saying
go? If you tell the truth, it's easy to
remember it, but to tell a lie, you
you're going to fail because you cannot
keep up with what you've been lying the
whole time. Evolution's been doing a
good job.
>> Yeah. Well, they they've got a few
cracks.
>> There are a couple of cracks in it.
Absolutely. There are cracks in it.
>> All right. So, let none think that in
attending these gatherings their duty is
done.
>> A mere attendance upon all the meetings
that are held will not itself bring a
blessing to the soul. If you're
receiving in these messages, fine. But
once you have received, you have to
share.
>> Yeah. And it's in sharing that you are
molded.
>> That's true.
>> Cuz you're you're always going to get a
positive response when you share, right,
Mark?
>> No, you're going to get clobbered.
>> No. But now you see while we're talking,
this is now the sharing part is also uh
once you've received, you share out to
outside because that's our main goal is
we have to go and evangelize. But this
also has to do look
where do you get this Holy Spirit where
do you or this convocation it is in the
church in camp meetings. So by
neglecting those
>> you're injuring your soul.
>> You're injuring your soul and it's in
there in the church in the camp where
you also get a little bit of
>> yes
>> uh confrontation sometimes
>> and remember each one has a different
spiritual gift but you have to exercise
it. Let's say your gift is hospitality.
>> You make people feel comfortable.
>> You know who had the gift of hospitality
in the Bible?
>> It was Lazarus's family.
>> Yeah.
>> Is it Martha?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Martha who was grumbling in the kitchen
and Mary was sitting at Jesus's feet and
Lazarus, I assume he was a relaxed guy.
And it was just so pleasing to be in
that house. There was no pressure.
>> You could
>> Yeah, that's why Jesus loved to go
there.
>> He could He could get a It's a place
where he could recharge a little bit.
>> Recharge his battery.
>> That is a gift of the Holy Spirit to be
able to do that.
>> So fascinating. There are different
things that you can do. So how do you
prepare for it? You have to allow the
Holy Spirit to mold you into that
condition. That's it. Hospitality,
friendliness,
and some may have the gift of teaching.
>> Well, there there people that like to
read a lot, that like to understand
things and try put things together. And
uh great if you can do that, but what's
the point if it goes to the grave and
and the worms eat it then?
>> No. Share
>> share it.
>> Share it. The other thing is also don't
force your gift onto somebody else
>> because that happens quite a lot. You
get agitated with other people that
doesn't don't do it like you.
>> Exactly. But you have your gifts and
other people have their gifts. You know,
there's a saying in African skunkas.
>> Yes.
>> Shoe maker. Stay with that which you're
good at.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So God calls you and God
wants you to use these gifts and in the
latter reign once you have exercised
these virtues
>> in the in the current situation
>> in the current situations then you will
naturally
>> just continue and you probably won't
even know that you have received the
latter rain. It'll just be so natural.
>> That's it. And and it will be so much
more effective.
>> Yes. So let us with contrite hearts pray
most earnestly that now in the time of
the latter rain the shells of grace may
fall upon us. At every meeting we attend
our prayers should ascend that at this
very time God will impart warmth and
moisture to our souls. As we seek God
for the Holy Spirit, it will work in us
meekness, humbleness of mind, a
conscience dependence upon God for the
perfecting latter rain. If we pray for
the blessing in faith, we shall receive
it as God has promised. There's no
presumption there. No, that's a very
important thing because presumption
>> is counter is Satan's counterfeit for
faith
>> 100%. That's what happened to Adam and
Eve.
>> Yes.
>> Especially Adam,
>> he was presumptuous. God wouldn't be so
exact.
>> Correct.
>> That was no faith.
How do you think Martin Luther felt
>> when he had to appear before all of
those prelates and uh papal nunios and
kings and emperors and
electors and standing there
>> alone?
>> Do you think he was presumptuous or was
he totally dependent upon God?
>> Totally dependent. I mean, isn't it true
if I remember correctly, he had he asked
for a little time?
>> Yes.
>> And he went
>> and prayed
>> and prayed and he came back and then
there was no presumption.
>> All right.
Do you think it would have been possible
for one man
despised
as he was by all of these people
to be able to make such an impact
if the Holy Spirit hadn't been there?
>> There's no way.
>> Impossible, right? Impossible. One man
overturned the world and Johan Hus
100 years before had said today you are
cooking a goose because huso means goose
>> but in 100 years from now there will
come one that you will not be able to
destroy.
>> Amazing right?
And we that was a early reign which
exemplifies what can happen to a greater
extent in the latter.
>> Exactly. Because that what I wanted to
say now is we are walking very quickly
towards similar situations that we're
going to be facing.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely.
The heavenly messengers seek to
communicate all that they receive from
God.
And what if they do that? Shouldn't that
be our aim as well?
>> Mhm.
>> If you if you've discovered something
and you say, "Wow,
what's the first thing you should do?
>> Order it or run and share it.
>> Share.
>> Club it afterwards." But that's
>> that's the thing. So be ready for
whatever you're going to face, but
share.
>> Share. The whole heavenly treasure
awaits our demand and reception.
And as we receive the blessing, we in
our turn are to impart it. Thus it is
that the holy lamps are fed and the
church becomes a lightbearer in the
world.
So the church consists of those that are
willing to bear the light.
This is the work that the Lord would
have every soul prepared to do at this
time when the four angels are holding
the four winds that they shall not blow
until the servants of God are sealed in
their foreheads.
There is no time now for selfpleasing.
So when those winds are let loose, then
the time of probation is over.
>> It's gone.
>> So you have to do the work now.
>> Now.
>> Right now. and uh self-pleasing must.
>> Isn't there a saying that says practice
makes perfect?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, how many people say I can't do
this?
>> Just don't practice the wrong things
that you get it perfect wrongly.
>> Oh, okay.
How how many people say I can't do this?
>> Well, the Bible is also full of them.
>> Moses said, "I can't do this."
>> The prophet said, "I can't do this.
Jonah said, "Kill me. I'm going to run
away. Throw me overboard. I don't care.
Kill me. I'm going to do this."
>> Who's there one that is it Jeremiah that
said, "I'm I'm finished preaching in
this name."
>> Cursed be the man that brought the
tidings to my to my family that a that a
male child was born. What the poor guy
have to do with it, right? He cursed
him. So, the Bible is full of those
things. But the the funny thing is they
all did it.
>> Yes.
They all did it.
>> Come through. And what helped them to
get through? The Holy Spirit.
>> Yes.
>> Was the one that
>> And once you did it,
then you can't really understand why you
didn't want to do it in the first place.
So there's no time now for
self-pleasing.
The lamp of the soul must be trimmed.
They must be supplied with the oil of
grace. Every precaution must be taken to
prevent spiritual declenion.
Lest the great day of the Lord overtake
us as a thief in the night.
Now the Bible says, "But ye, brethren,
are not in darkness that it should
overtake ye as a thief." Right.
>> Exactly.
>> We should be knowing what where we are
in the stream of time.
If we walk the straight and narrow by
the help of the Holy Spirit and God
working in us,
>> then we can be ready that won't overtake
us like a thief in the night. This is
like this is the preparing. This is will
you be able to stand? Imagine if you
read any of this,
do you see any
uh drum set
that you beat like a pagan drum to see
if you can get an outpouring of some
spirit that will put you into an altered
state of consciousness? Do you see
anything like this?
>> No, I also don't see any confusion and
rolling around on the floor.
>> None of it. This is all practical advice
>> of what it entails. So you must be
steeped in the word.
You must understand the issue of the
day. You must have practiced sharing it.
And you must have reaped the benefits of
that which you have shared because it's
a double-edged sword, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Even if it became negative,
>> it's fine.
>> Because sometimes the negative will make
you dig deeper. Yes.
>> So that you can understand it even
better. Because sometimes you might have
also had a little bit of a skew
understanding.
>> Yes. And you know to be to be sealed is
to be so settled in the truth
>> that you cannot be moved.
>> But to be settled in the truth doesn't
mean to be deceived in a lie.
>> No.
>> So where do you find the truth? You try
find it in that word. Mhm.
>> And once you have found it and you have
internalized it and you've accepted it,
then no matter what anybody says to the
contrary, you can't be moved.
>> That's it.
>> Whether you take the Sabbath issue,
whether you take the state of the dead
issue,
>> I mean, if somebody confronts you, but I
know because you know, my deceased
father appeared to me or whatever,
>> you won't be able to be moved by
something like that because the word
says otherwise.
>> Yeah. We have to be settled in that.
Correct.
We may have long followed the narrow
path, but it is not safe to take this as
proof that we shall follow it to the
end.
If the righteous man turns from his
righteousness and does that which is
evil in the sight of the Lord, none of
his former righteousness will be
remembered. He will surely die.
If the wicked man or the unrighteous man
turns from his evil ways and does what
is right in the eyes of the Lord, none
of his former wickedness will be
remembered. He will surely live. Turn
from your evil ways for why would you
die, oh house of Israel. Ezekiel say
that or something to that effect.
>> All right. So there's no guarantee that
if you followed the path that you can
now be complacent.
So that's not a safe thing to do. If we
have walked with God in fellowship of
the spirit, it is because we have sought
him daily
by faith.
But those who do not cultivate the
spirit and habit of prayer cannot expect
to receive the golden oil of goodness,
patience, longsuffering,
gentleness, and love. Martin, what are
those? the fruits of the spirit. Fruit
of the spirit
>> and their character as
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And that's that's the
those are the ones that uh
you feel as if you're bleeding from the
>> why
>> working on it.
>> But aren't they all in harmony with our
our nature?
>> Well, not mine.
>> The heart is deceitful above all things
and desperately wicked. And sometimes
you'll be doing some I I I was actually
sitting one day and I think I was on the
phone. Yes. And the more that I talk,
the more that I say to myself, you
should be quiet now. And the more that
my mouth is going like this and I said
be quiet, but it doesn't want to stop.
So the flesh and the
>> Did the brakes not work?
>> No.
So I Yeah, it's still a struggle.
All right, Martin. So, we have to
nurture goodness,
>> patience.
My mother-in-law used to call me her,
Mr. Impatience.
So, this has been a a major major hurdle
and uh longsuffering,
gentleness,
and love. So Martin these are all
character issues
>> but how do you receive them? How do you
work on it? It has a answer there.
>> Yes. Well, the Lord puts you in that
crucible
and he makes you confront your
skewed character attributes over and
over and over again.
And one of the best places, if I may say
so, to be in a crucible is with the
brethren.
>> Yes. in a ministry in a church.
>> Yeah. Paul said, you know, he was he was
beaten with rods. He had received the
lashings.
He was shipwrecked.
>> Stoned.
>> He was stoned and left for dead.
But the cherry on top was the brethren.
>> Yeah.
And if you read the spirit of prophecy,
then it tells us that the Lord permitted
that Paul should go to sleep earlier
than he should have because of the
brethren.
>> Sure.
>> So, Martin uh the church is sometimes a
good place to practice patience,
longsuffering,
gentleness, and love. But if I read this
also correctly, if you're going to do it
without the habit of prayer,
>> you're going to forget it.
>> You can forget it.
>> Okay. Everyone is to keep himself
separate from the world. That's another
difficult one, right?
>> What does that do with ecommenism?
>> That's gone. And politically correct is
also gone.
>> Politically correct is gone.
>> Okay.
Which is full of iniquity.
We are not to walk with God for a time
and then part from his company and walk
in the sparks of our own kindling
or be double-minded.
>> We are called to proclaim the special
truths for this time. You can take each
one of these sentences,
>> you can break it down
>> and they can they can hit like a hammer,
right? That's why sometimes this is how
you read and even Bible verses.
Internalize it. See what this is meaning
to you.
>> If you're constantly running up against
the brick wall when you proclaim special
truths for this time,
what do you do?
>> You just pray and carry on
>> and carry on. Reminds me my wife was
doing coal porter drinking
>> and she tried it for a while
>> and so she went from door to door. She
she had a naturally timid disposition
and she got to this house
and the man let her in and then he
locked the door
and uh he didn't uh do anything strange
or anything like that but it was rather
you know disturbing
and then he let her have it because uh
of what she was presenting and he didn't
like that theology and eventually he
physically threw her out the house and
she was very very upset
and she wanted to give up. And then she
said, "No, I'm I'm going to I'm going to
carry on. I'm going to try once more."
And she got to the next house
and uh there was a cleaning lady who
opened the door and as she opened the
door the little dog ran out
and the lady was desperate because she
was responsible for the dog and now the
dog was out. So my wife ran after the
dog and picked it up and the dog
panicked
and uh
>> let it loose.
>> Let it loose. Yeah. And spread diarrhea
over
her whole attire.
And so she was covered in diarrhea.
And she was exceedingly upset. She
brought the dog back, went home,
showered,
washing, put on new clothes, and was
determined to give up. And this little
voice said, "Don't give up once more."
>> So, she went back and she went to the
third house, and there the people were
interested and wanted to know
everything. And sometimes you go through
that process. I think that's
longsuffering as well. You just Gary is
the circumstances weren't very pleasant,
>> you know, being beaten up and you're
worried and then being pooed over and
then finally. So, you need to pray
and uh if you believe and you trust in
God, it is the time for the latter rain
when the Lord will give largely of his
spirit. Be fervent in prayer and watch
in the spirit. Now, can you only read
this here or can you find this in the
Bible? It's
>> everywhere. Quoted from the Bible.
>> It's everywhere.
>> You get it?
>> So, these are testimonies to ministers.
So, those are the issues that you need
to bear in mind once you are still on
that battered ship.
>> Yeah. And this is we should start
praying for the latter rain. But we
should also know that we have to use the
current reign, the early reign, the Holy
Spirit working in us.
>> All right. Now, some people will say,
"Well, why can't I jump off the ship?
Why do I need to sit on that stupid
thing?"
>> Well, the Bible says, "And the spirit
and the bride
>> say, come." Christ has a bride.
>> And the Bible says, "These are they that
keep the commandments of God and have
the testimony of Jesus and the faith of
Jesus."
>> And these are they that keep the
commandments so that they may have the
right to the tree of life. So, there are
special attributes here. Yeah.
>> You can't just ignore them.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Some some people are afraid.
>> For this time of trouble. Is that right?
>> Very true.
>> I think most people and like we've me
did that other one uh a while back. Uh
it's an overwhelming surprise that will
be um catching the world.
>> Yes.
>> So somehow a little bit afraid to what
how should we be?
Doesn't the Bible say
that one will put a thousand to flight?
No.
Now, that's impossible without uh God
working on your behalf, right?
So, here we have a promise of angelic
protection in the time of trouble. It
comes from Marinata.
In the day of fierce trial, he Christ
will say, "Come, my people, enter thou
into thy chambers and shut thy doors
about thee. Hide thyself as it were for
a little moment until the indignation be
overpassed." Obviously, this is after
the close of probation.
>> Yes. So, this is after the ship has
already struck. Everything has gone. So,
now the latter rain has come. That has
passed.
>> That's gone.
>> Yeah.
Then you will be dwelling in the secret
place of the most high. Isn't that
right?
>> That's true. So,
>> so what are the chambers in which they
are to hide? They are the protected of
Christ and holy angels. The people of
God are not at this time all in one
place. They are in different companies
and in all parts of the earth. I saw the
saints leaving the cities and villages
and associating together in companies
and living in the most solitary places.
Angels provided them food and water
while the wicked were suffering from
hunger and thirst. Now Martin, is this
only a promise here or is this to be
found in Psalms 91?
>> Yes.
>> A thousand will fall by your side,
10,000 at your right hand it shall not
come near you. No.
>> And all of those promises are right
there in Psalms 91. They are for the
time of trouble. So here we're dealing
with the post probation time period. So
maybe it's important just to bring back
a little just before this because a lot
of people when you have clear
instructions that you must look after
yourself out of the cities out of into
the country prepare get for um a self a
piece of land to produce your own food
there's some people that say no but
>> according to this God and the angels
will look after you
>> that's in the time of trouble in little
time of trouble before the close of
probation. There will be a time period
>> when you will still be able to do
certain things. It'll be hard.
>> Yeah.
>> But uh God will take care of it. And it
says you will come out in companies. If
you can't do it by yourself, God will
open away.
>> Yeah.
>> So the point is do not be anxious.
>> The Bible says my people will not leave
in haste
>> because they will be prepared. The same
when Jerusalem fell. When you see
standing in the holy place the
abomination of desolation,
let the as spoken of by the prophet
Daniel, may the reader understand. They
understood and they left
>> quietly.
>> Quietly.
So angels provided them food and water.
During the night, a very impressive
scene passed before me. There seemed to
be great confusion and the conflict of
armies. A messenger from the Lord stood
before me and said, "Call your
household. I will lead you. Follow me."
He led me down a dark passage through a
forest, then through the cliffs of
mountains and said, "Here you are safe."
Now, not not everybody will be led like
that. Some will actually be in dungeons
or you may have been arrested.
then God will take care of you there
too.
>> What did he do for Peter in the dungeon
in the in the
>> exactly the same thing? The gods fell
asleep. The chains fell off him.
>> The doors opened and he walked out.
>> And he walked out. There were others who
had been led to this retreat. The
heavenly messenger said, "The time of
trouble has come as a thief in the night
as the Lord warned you it would come."
In the time of trouble, just before the
coming of Christ, the righteous will be
preserved through the ministration of
heavenly angels.
>> So sometimes there will be rioters,
Martin, and they will want to even
attack those that claim to keep the
commandments and hold to the testimony.
And then angels in the form of men of
war will intercede and stop them from
performing whatever they want to
perform.
>> Also just important this is what we are
talking about in the time of trouble.
This is after the close of probation.
>> After the close of
>> because before that they will
unfortunately or fortunately it depends
on how you see it be martyrs.
>> Yes.
>> But there will be no security for the
transgressor of God's law. So, the time
of trouble is more serious for the
transgressor than it is for God's
prevented. Angels cannot then protect
those who are disregarding one of the
divine precepts.
In the closing period of earth's
history, the Lord will work mightily in
behalf of those who stand steadfastly
for the right. In the midst of the time
of trouble, trouble such as has not been
since there was a nation. His chosen
ones will stand unmoved.
What? Anyone can be part of the chosen.
Yeah.
Because those that do the will of the
Lord, those are the chosen ones.
>> It's your choice.
>> Yes. Satan with all the hosts of evil
cannot destroy the weakest of God's
saints. Angels that excel in strength
will protect them. And in the their
behalf, Jehovah will reveal himself as a
God of gods, able to save to the
uttermost those who have put their trust
in him. Doesn't the Bible say he will he
will put his angels he will give his
angels charge over you?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So important to realize here
we've got the the latter reign that we
were speaking about. So people wanted to
know how will we able to stand through
prayer. get the l get yourself in the
former reign ready for the latter rain.
Then we'll you go to the close of
probation.
>> Yes.
>> And you don't have to start like you
just mentioned earlier, you don't have
to stress yourself into a coma.
>> No.
>> You put your faith in God and he will do
the rest for you.
>> And in the moments of secret prayer, do
some serious introspection.
>> Yes. That's what we have to get to now.
>> Saying, "Lord, am I right?" Mhm. Is this
is this what you want me to be like?
>> I have character defects. Can you help
me to overcome them? I have thoughts
running through my mind. I just had a
long conversation with a with a young
man who was in in serious in a serious
condition
and he wants the way out. Now the way of
out is clearly spelled out but you must
take a step in that direction. You know
you have to put your foot into the
Jordan.
>> Yeah.
>> Before the waters will cease.
And uh how many times do I have people
saying I want to do the right thing
and I'm going to put my foot in the
Jordan. And you see them a year later
and they're
>> they're totally transformed. M
>> haven't we seen this in our ministry
over and over and over again
>> many times.
>> So Martin introspection for the time of
trouble is absolutely
>> essential. So Martin that was all spirit
of prophecy. Shall we read a little bit
of Bible?
>> Yeah let's put it together see if it's
in harmony.
>> Okay. Now Thessalonians has a nice
little section on such preparations. 1
Thessalonians chapter 5.
But of the times and the seasons,
brethrens, you have no need that I write
unto you. For you yourselves know
perfectly
that the day of the Lord so cometh as a
thief in the night.
Please don't stop reading there.
>> No, that's the most important thing.
Read the whole thing.
>> How many people quote that?
>> Everybody. Especially
>> when they want to go to a secret
rapture.
>> Yes. All right. So, don't worry about
it.
For when they shall say peace and
safety, then sudden destructions comes
upon them as travail upon a woman with
child and they shall not escape.
So peace and safety when they start
talking that when you can plainly see
there is no peace and there is no safety
in this world, right?
>> There's no justice in it either. No,
>> the thief walks on the streets
>> and uh the murderer is set free.
Uh the molester and the rapist makes a
plea bargain and walks the streets. It's
unbelievable, right?
>> Yeah.
>> But ye, brethren, this is where you must
pick up the story again in verse four,
are not in darkness that that day should
overtake you as a thief. Can we please
remember that?
>> So,
>> so that's what I want to talk about in
the next one. Why is it not possible for
those that are steeped in the word of
God to be caught like a thief in the
night?
>> It's so important because this gives you
hope. This gives you peace
>> because you can put your faith in that
if God is working in this current reign
and you listen and you you won't be
overtaken. You won't be you will be
expecting it.
>> Yeah.
>> In fact, you would be welcoming it
>> because the alternative
>> a continuation of the situation that we
have in the world today is just
unbearable.
>> I mean, how many tears are flowing
>> into the rivers on a daily basis because
of the condition of this world? I
certainly hope that it'll end soon.
>> Me too. Ye are all the children of
light.
Martin, thy word is a lamp unto my feet
and a and a light unto my path. And you
are children of the day. We are not of
the night nor of darkness. Therefore,
let us not sleep as do others, but let
us watch and be sober.
What is that loudian church doing?
>> Snoring.
>> Snoring. Snoring. So, it's not watching.
>> I see someone who said we should stop
laughing because we're living in very
serious times.
>> Maybe we can just explain again. We know
exactly what serious times it is. And
it's not a sarcastic laugh about it. It
is a laugh of knowing that we also have
some work to do still.
>> Yes.
>> And that we sit with these things and we
see it and when we see a a snoring and
we read it, then it's wow.
>> Yeah. Let's just carry on.
So let us not sleep as do others, but
let us watch and be sober. For they that
sleep sleep in the night,
>> and they that be drunken are drunken in
the night. But let us who are of the day
be sober,
>> putting on the breastplate of faith,
love, and for a helmet the hope of
salvation.
For God has not appointed us to wroth,
but to obtain salvation by our Lord
Jesus Christ. Okay. Must you know Christ
in order to internalize that?
>> You must know the true Christ and what
he's done for you.
>> No fake Christ. Now what what if you
have this hard task master uh picture of
Christ waiting to throw you into
purgatory so that he can purge your sins
over the next millennium
>> because you you slipped up once.
>> So no
>> no I don't have a God like that. Do you
have one like that?
>> No. That's also not the Jesus of the
Bible. You also don't have a Jesus of
the Bible that says, "Oh, you carry on
doing what you're doing. I'll I'm okay
because you once said I'm Jes."
>> Yes.
>> That also doesn't work.
>> All right. So, I need to know Christ. I
need to know the character of Christ and
I need to have befriended Christ.
>> Yes. He must be your king and your
friend.
>> And your friend and your brother.
>> And your brother. Your savior.
>> All of it.
>> Okay.
It continues
because he died for us.
>> So surely
he must be kind-hearted. He must be
caring.
Whether we wake or sleep, we should live
together with him. The only reason why
you would want to live together with him
is because you have a personal
relationship with him.
>> So is it important to nurture a
relationship like that?
And wherefore comfort yourselves
together and edify one another
even as also ye do.
The Bible also says and they came
together frequently
>> breaking bread
>> and they ate together.
>> Yes.
>> And they shared their experiences
together. This is what strengthens
people.
And we beseech you, brethren, to know
them which labor amongst you, and are
over you in the Lord, and admonish you,
and to esteem them very highly in love
for their work's sake, and be at peace
amongst yourselves.
Does this happen all the time in the
church, Martin?
>> This is what we have to work towards for
sure. If this isn't happening,
>> no, it's not happening. So when you know
it's not happening, then we have to work
in it. There must be some work to be
done, right? Yeah. Okay. And sometimes
you have to look at somebody in a new
light cuz maybe you know there are
certain things that irritate you about
someone
>> and stop looking at the negative.
>> Yes.
>> And look at the positive and
uh see what a friendly word can do.
>> You know the devil keeps us very busy.
>> Yes.
>> With negative thoughts, assumptions.
Yes.
>> All sorts of things. When like you just
said, just
even though you're walking in with a
mindset,
go and try something friendly.
>> Be friendly.
>> Have you given someone that you don't
really like a hug lady and a smile?
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So, those are little things
that we can we can start nurturing and
practicing. All right. And this is for
love's sake. For love's sake. Now we
exhort your brethren, warn them that are
unruly, comfort the feeble-minded,
support the weak, be patient towards all
men. Are we doing that?
>> I thought it's only those that you like.
>> I think it's particularly those that you
don't like.
>> Patient toward all.
>> Martin, is that easy?
>> Well, I was just thinking about myself
right now. And there's definitely this
is what we have to start practicing
>> through prayer. This is the Holy Spirit
working now.
>> Is it easy to cuddle up to a porcupine?
>> Uh from the front. You can maybe try a
little bit.
>> Not even from the front. What if you you
get as close as possible to the
porcupine and ask them just to settle
down their spines for a little bit and
then get a little bit closer? Yeah.
>> I mean, even a porcupine has to mate,
right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. And a porcupine, if tame
ones are very cuddly.
>> Are they cuddly?
>> Yeah. Well, that's what I've heard.
>> Have you Have you had a a tame
porcupine?
>> No, I've only had two wild porcupines in
the middle of the night on my deck in
front.
>> And what was your attitude?
>> I had to stand and get away because they
didn't want to let me go. So,
>> are you telling me you were not kind and
long-suffering towards them? No, I have
to definitely be more patient to that.
>> See that none render evil for evil unto
any man, but ever follow that which is
good, both amongst yourselves and to all
men. Rejoice ever more. Pray without
ceasing.
In everything give thanks, for this is
the will of God in Christ Jesus
concerning you. And quench not the
spirit. This is good advice for
receiving the latter rain. You practice
those things.
>> We have to This must be our daily
um exercise routine.
>> How do you quench the Holy Spirit?
>> By refusing to budge.
>> Just doing if there's something we had
actually had a a conversation a little
bit earlier and I that's one thing that
I've always remembered. If you ask God,
God, show me things that I have to still
change, then you're going to get uh and
hear from the Holy Spirit. And then you
have to decide if you're going to quench
it or not.
>> Okay? When there's things that you know
that you have to change, you you know
it. And then what is this doing in the
middle of this?
He's talking about character and he's
talking about all of these things. And
then he says, "Despise not
prophesyings."
>> It's like the brethren the pro it's
because it's definitely going to be
done.
>> But Martin, they will tell you when you
start this that you're a conspiracy
theorist.
>> Yeah. You're a traveler of the what? The
troubler.
>> What is that?
>> A trouble of Israel.
>> Yeah. Disturber of the brethren. And
then you have to prove all things. Hold
fast that which is good. Does that mean
you have to have a filter in place?
>> Definitely. And don't not go and taste
all the alcohol and the bad things out
there and keep what's good. That's not
what it means here.
>> No. Abstain from all appearance of evil.
>> That's a tough one, right? And the very
God of peace sanctify you holy. We've
just had a long list
of what it means to be sanctified.
>> Yeah. But
your
>> and pray God your whole spirit and soul
and body be preserved blameless unto the
coming of our Lord Jesus Christ.
Faithful is he that calleth you who also
will do it. Do you have to do it in your
own strength?
>> This is the crux of the whole matter.
And that's why we have to speak about
that. Who stands between you and God?
>> You. you
>> you're the only one who stands there.
You're the only one. And through getting
all of this, the peace among the
brethren, the all of this, like we
mentioned in the earlier, there's a eye
problem. There's a eye problem. Remember
that uh
train vision or that u train station
vision
>> Mhm.
>> where all that sought position
>> were no longer there after this terrible
shaking that had taken place. If you are
constantly striving to be the boss man,
then you will not be easily
approachable.
>> No.
>> What? When you walk into the place, do
people want to avoid you because you are
overbearing or bossy or this or
something else or do people radiate
towards you? What did they do to Jesus?
Didn't they radiate towards him?
>> Yeah.
>> And they all came to him with all their
troubles and eventually the disciples
says, you know, go away with all of
these things and don't bother the master
now. And what are all these children
doing here? And he had time for them
all.
>> You see, now that brings us back to that
portion. Who were flocking to him? Those
who knew they needed him.
>> Yes. the others who thought no they okay
on their own
>> the presumptive ones.
>> Yeah. You've got even the disciples
get away here.
>> Yeah.
>> So is that an object lesson for us?
>> That's an object lesson. Yes. So we we
need to look at ourselves and ask
ourselves
what is the consequence of my presence?
That's what
>> is it scattering or is it drawing?
>> And am I going to um learn from it or
and I'm going to see if this is biblical
to change on it?
>> Yes. What do you get out of the
statement which says when I be lifted up
I will draw all men to you to me.
>> Uh the lifting up is a demonstration of
the character of God.
someone who is willing to die for you.
>> Yeah.
>> And there's no coercion in it.
It's just looking at that character and
contemplating that character that draws
you to it like a like a moth to the to
the light.
>> So these are actually the things that
prepare us for the latter, right? Can we
say that?
>> That's it. This is a way you're going to
be working on your character.
>> Yes.
>> Transforming it now with the help of the
Holy Spirit to be ready for the latter
rain.
>> So let's read it again in these
writings. Jesus emptied himself in all
that he did. Self did not appear. Isn't
that what we just said? Didn't we just
get that out of the Bible?
>> 100%.
>> He subordinated all things to the will
of his father. when his mission on earth
was about to close, he could say, "I
have glorified thee on the earth." So,
we have to glorify Christ. That is our
mission. And
exposing false doctrine that places a
negative view upon this character of God
is a necessary thing sometimes. Although
some people will perceive it as
attacking or harsh or whatever,
but if they if they place the character
of Christ in a wrong light, is it not
our duty to correct it?
>> I I believe it is.
>> Then you can say, I finished the work
which thou gavest me to do just like
Jesus said. And he bids us, learn of me,
for I am meek and lowly in heart. If any
man will come after me, let him deny
himself. Let self be dethroned and no
longer hold the supremacy of the self.
As you said, that's the biggest obstacle
between us and Christ.
The biggest one is the self.
He who beholds Christ in his
self-denial, his loneliness of heart,
will be constrained to say, as did
Daniel when he beheld one like the sons
of men, my cliness was turned in me to
corruption.
So what Daniel was saying, everything
that I thought was grand and cool about
me is actually
>> and what I've done,
>> rubbish.
everything that I've done, the way that
I preached, the way that I'm I'm just
and when you beheld Christ, you say,
"Oh, I'm nothing."
>> So the independence and self-supreacy in
which we glory are seen in their true
vileeness as tokens of servitude to
Satan.
>> That is strong words.
>> Well, that's exactly what Daniel just
said. His comeliness, that which was
cool and wonderful, was corruption. It
means it's dead. It means nothing.
Human nature is ever struggling for
expression, ready for contest. But he
who learns of Christ is emptied of self,
of pride, of love, of supremacy, and
there is silence in the soul. Self is
yielded to the disposal of the Holy
Spirit. Is there any room for narcissism
here?
>> Not at all. And that is something that's
really gotten out now. how people can
understand how the thought pattern of
certain people become.
>> All right. So, narcissism is actually an
attribute of Satan.
>> Yeah, for sure. When you want to
manipulate people and control people and
gaslight people and all of these things,
then you should really sit down, have
some serious introspection.
And because you cannot in your own
strength change those attributes, you
have to learn to surrender to Christ.
And you can only do that in the inner
chamber in the prayer room.
So you see what's important is if you've
listened to this and you say but I'm not
like that. Make sure do the
introspection pray and make sure because
when Satan is supremacy is in your life
you won't even realize sometimes
>> you won't realize it
>> that this is what you are doing to
others.
>> Can you grant the same freedom
to others that you wish for yourself?
That's a very good test that you have in
all spheres and in all levels.
>> And if you have this propensity to
control others work and actions,
>> even if you think it's with good
intention,
>> yes, can you hold it back?
>> That's what you have to do.
>> And now the worst of it. Let's say
you're extremely capable at something
>> and you find someone who is doing it in
an extremely incapable way. Is there a
way in which you can address the issue
that is non-narcissistic?
>> It's so important. What does it mean to
be in that to non-narcissistic? It means
>> selflessly help someone.
>> Yes. So not
>> as opposed to bossing him around.
>> Not telling him that actually you're
doing it wrong. You should only be doing
it the I'm doing it.
>> Yes.
>> No. All right. So what does this all
mean? self is yielded to the disposal of
the Holy Spirit. That's the alternative.
>> Then we are not anxious to have the
highest place. We have no ambition to
crowd and elbow ourselves into notice
that we feel that our highest place is
at the feet of our savior.
So Martin if you constantly angling for
this position and the disciples were all
doing it. I love this this statement.
You all by yourself into I'm I'm getting
in here. I'm going to be
>> Jesus says go and sit in that back row
and then when the master comes and says
friend come up higher
that's not embarrassing but the reverse
is exceedingly embarrassing. Okay.
>> I love it.
We looked at Jesus waiting for his hand
to lead, listening for his voice to
guide. The Apostle Paul had this
experience and he said, "I am crucified
with Christ. Nevertheless, I live. Yet
not I, but Christ liveth in me. And the
life which I now live in the flesh I
live by the faith of the son of God who
loved me and gave himself for me." This
is a transformation that takes place
when you allow Christ into the heart.
>> Yeah.
>> But then you in order to do that you
have to dethrone self. And then when
you've done that like we've spoken
before just to bring it back. Then
you've let the early rain work. Then
imagine just what the latter rain can do
when you bring it to us.
>> And then it is safe to sit with him in
his throne.
>> Yeah. Oh yes. or else you will be a
tyrant and a hard task master.
>> You become like Satan.
>> So when we receive Christ as an abiding
guest in the soul, the peace of God
which passes all understanding will keep
our hearts and minds through Christ
Jesus. The Savior's life on earth,
though lived in the midst of conflict,
was a life of peace. While angry enemies
were constantly pursuing them, he said,
"He that sent me is with me. The Father
has not left me alone, for I do always
those things that please him." Quoting
John 8:29, "No storm of human or satanic
wroth could disturb the calm of that
perfect communion with God." That's why
he could sleep in the boat
>> while everything was raging.
>> Master, do you not care?
>> Yeah.
>> Is that not what they said? And this is
what we're going to be facing. We're
going to be asking, "Where are you?
>> Where are you? Look, look at what looks
like
>> going to happening to this this church.
Look at this barge. It's in a mess."
And he said, "Take my yoke upon you and
learn of me, for I am meek and lowly of
heart, and you shall find rest. Bear
with me the yoke of service for the
glory of God and the uplifting of
humanity, and you will find the yoke
easy, and the burden light. It is the
love of self that destroys our peace. So
Martin, these are all very important
things for receiving the latter rain.
So while self is alive, we stand ready
continually to guard it from
mortification and insult.
>> So we're very protective of this self.
>> Very protective. But when we are dead
and our life is hid with Christ in God,
we shall not take neglect or slights to
heart. We shall be deaf to reproach and
blind to scorn and insult.
So obviously you're going to receive
those.
>> Yeah. But you're not going to be
perturbed by it.
>> Yes. You're not going to have a speed
wobble.
>> Yeah. Nervous breakdown because somebody
in the church or somebody there
>> said something mean. How many people
say, "Well, they weren't kind to me. I'm
never going back."
>> Exactly. No.
>> Suffer long.
>> It also comes back. Why do you want to
jump the ship? Because it's getting a
little bit hard to go through the the
other stuff.
>> Yeah. But swimming across that ocean is
also a little bit hard.
>> I think that's a little bit harder.
>> Yes. So, love suffereth long. It's kind.
It env.
Not itself. We know all of these. You
know, it hopes all things. endureth all
things. It never fails.
I think God gave us families and
children so that we can learn these
things in a small circle
and then apply it to a bigger circle
>> and then to be ready to apply it in
heaven.
>> If you if you have children, you learn
that you forgive whatever they have done
even if it is a terrible thing and start
again.
And uh some people may not do that but
uh generally speaking that is what you
learn in a family
>> or in a relationship like a marriage.
Fortunately you never have to say sorry.
Hey Martin
>> no let's let's leave it. So happiness
drawn from earthly sources is a
changeable is as changeable as varying
circumstances can make it. But the peace
of Christ is a constant and abiding
peace. It does not depend on any
circumstances in life, on the amount of
worldly goods or the number of earthly
friends. Christ is the fountain of
living water and happiness drawn from
him can never fail.
So you can know times of prosperity, you
can know times of poverty,
but if you have love, you can get
through all of them.
So the meekness of Christ manifested in
the home will make the inmates happy.
>> That's it's just true.
>> And it will be in church as well.
>> Yes. Same with the church. It provokes
no quarrel, gives back no angry answers,
soothes the irritated temper, diffuses a
gentleness that is felt by all within
its charmed circle. Wherever cherished,
it makes the families of earth a part of
the one great family above. So that's
the practicing ground. We have lots of
practicing ground
>> and we're right in it now. And so if we
want to get through this, let's start
practicing this.
>> Ah okay, Martin. So we can practice in
the inner circle.
>> Mhm. in the slightly bigger circle in
our case now clash of minds
or varity or the church or
>> or the conference or the union or the
division or the worldwide church.
>> That's it. It's all part of the family.
>> And everywhere you go, you will find
people that need comfort.
>> Definitely. And everywhere you go, you
will find bullies and narcissists.
>> It's part of the deal.
>> And we all have to work on our character
because all of us have a eye problem.
Correct. Rid of it.
>> So far better would it be for us to
suffer under false accusation
than to inflict upon ourselves the
torture of retaliation upon our enemies.
The spirit of hatred and revenge
originated with Satan and can bring only
evil to him who cherishes it. Sometimes
I think it's it's necessary to set the
record straight.
>> Yes. But not with a vengeance, not with
it depends on your spirit with what
you're doing.
>> Set the record straight and then be
prepared to push the reset button.
Get it out. Talk it out and reset.
>> But then really reset.
>> Yes.
>> Don't dig it up.
>> No. When it's along the line,
>> two years ago, you did that and I still
remember it today. And you're not going
to get away with it.
>> Exactly.
>> If Jesus had to forgive you like that,
how would that go?
>> Uh, he's not supposed to do that with
me, but I'm allowed to do it with
others, right? Doesn't make sense. No.
>> Okay. So don't retaliate.
You can discuss it. The Bible says do
that. If your brother has a problem with
you, go and sort it out. Doesn't the
Bible say that?
>> Yeah.
>> If he doesn't want to listen, take
someone with him. If it they don't want
to listen, then take it to the church.
You can go the whole hog.
But uh when you treat someone like a tax
collector,
remember how Jesus treated the tax
collector. I just want to earn something
in here. Um, and don't be a aen.
>> If you know that you are guilty of
something,
>> confess your sins and carry on.
>> Don't let it go through the whole place
and eventually when it gets to you and
you still don't want to acknowledge,
then you just say sorry just because
you're caught.
>> Yes. So loneliness of heart, that
meekness which is the fruit of an
abiding Christ is the true secret of
blessing. He will beautify the meek with
salvation. Psalms 149 verse4.
So Martin, we could have given a long
list of preparations for the latter rain
and
>> for the time of trouble where we say,
you know, purchase this, purchase that,
keep that in your house, uh have your
storoom ready and you know all the
physical things.
>> But the physical things won't save you.
>> No. and and it won't bring you the
peace.
>> No. So, it's more important that we we
first look at the spiritual
and not leave the the latter undone. I I
believe that when you really let the
Holy Spirit work and you get the your
relationship ready and practice these
things and that transform
transformation,
the Lord will impress you on getting
that other things done.
>> He'll take care of that too. So I would
like to end on this little quote.
Mild measures,
soft answers,
pleasant words are much better fitted to
reform and save than severity and
harshness.
Is that the best preparation for
an abundance of rain? Yeah, from what
we've read just now, we are in
practicing and in right now. So, we're
in a school.
>> Yes. In a crucible,
>> in a curriculum
and uh the failure rate is often high.
>> Yeah. But uh let's strive to enter into
the gate via the narrow path.
>> That's it. And maybe we can just remind
everybody that don't believe that you've
arrived.
>> No, nobody has arrived. We're all on a
journey.
>> So let's support each other. You know,
sometimes in a marathon you see
where somebody will even give up his
first place to go and help someone who's
really struggling. I think that is the
way to run it.
>> Let's run it that way. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father,
we want to be ready for the latter rain.
We have to be steeped in the word. We
have to understand the road map. We have
to know where we are going. We must
understand the obstacles that need to be
overcome. We need to be ready in season
and out of season with words of
admonition, words of encouragement.
And we need to have the attributes
within us before we can share them with
others. So I pray to help us in this
regard and bring us to that point where
we can walk in unity with our brethren
so that in unity we can cry loud and
bring others to the point where they can
see the truths which separate the
righteous from the unrighteous. That's
my prayer in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Heat. Heat.